hello everyone and welcome back to the
1970 palma de mallorca inter-zonal
tournament it's Bobby Fischer versus the
drag would mean each now Bobby Fischer
had an excellent winning streak in this
tournament he defeated five five of them
then he had four draws and one loss
against bent Larsen and then again he
played two excellent games beating FM
Geller and borislav Eve Cove and now he
again has his winning streak back and
now he faces Yugoslavia's international
master I will diminish who wonder well
he won't shared first in 1962 with
Alexander Matano which what he also
represented Yugoslavia in two Chess
Olympiad where he won I believe six and
a half out of eight points so really
doing a lot for the team and he was also
a second to set to star glitch and later
Luca Merli buuck so definitely a strong
player and he was considered to be an
expert of the Sicilian defense so it's
very interesting what Fischer uses
against him in this game which is the
black pieces so uh before we check out
the game we do have a nice photo
challenge it's gonna be a really
difficult one but then again best of
luck to you here it is who is this young
chess player here so there you have it
it's a bit of a blurry photo but it is
some twenty years old so you know photos
weren't that that sharply back then so
there you have it best of luck to
everyone and now let's check out the
game we have E for by minge
and the official replies with Knight to
f6 so Fischer goes for the idea hence
defense we have E 5 attacking the knight
which is the idea of the aliens defense
you want to provoke wise from pushing
response and then undermine them later
Knight to d5 let me just fix that Knight
to d5 d4 we have d6 and now C for
attacking the knight some people enjoy
c4 here I myself prefer Knight to f3 but
you know that's I don't think any move
is better it's just a personal
preference
c4 Knights to b6 and now he captures on
d6 also I believe one of the favorites
was f4 completely going into the four
pawns attack against the addition and
was aliens idea he wanted to provoke all
of these pawns and then undermine them
later wood moves like d66 c5a but in the
game a minute goes for he captures and
v6c captures on d6 and Knight to c3 g6
Fischer prepares the vignette or the
Bishop Bishop to d3 Bishop to g7 90 G to
helping out with the defense of the d4
pawn we have castles b3 now Knight to c6
and Bishop to e3 as the pawn on d4 was
attacked twice d5 Fisher thinks it's
okay to waste a temple like Carson did
in his yesterday's game against Mahmoud
er of in Biel and here we have c5 I'm
not going for the exchange in the center
because this would of course only favor
black after captures captures captures
I've just activated blacks Queen and
black is now free free to develop at
will so after d5 closing the position c5
but now as the pawn already advanced so
far Fischer goes and Knight to d7
preparing a five and now he will
undermine White's Center Bishop to b5
pushes d5 we have castles and now what
do you do here with the black pieces
Knight captures on c5 Fischer invites me
need to go D captures on c5 and then
Fischer would simply push the pawn and
after something going 94 capture any
three characters and after Bishop to e6
simply continue developing white would
be stuck with this week III coin for the
rest of the game and if if minish wants
to you know ruin Fischer's pawn
structure as well then he will no longer
have any bishops and fit the Fischer
will have a nice bit of repair so after
night the c5 d captures on e5 instead of
capturing the night and now d4 we have
Knight captures and now Fischer place
tonight captures on e5 h 3 we have
Knights the e6
Knight captures Bishop captures and here
already
move 18 for drag will diminish a
critical moment in the game probably the
best thing to do would be captured a
queen and after Luke capture simply go
rook c1 as you know there could be some
nasty discoveries here with this bishop
and the night
after a sex moving the bishop bishop to
let's say yeah f5 and it would be a nice
game for everyone the materials
completely queer equal on the board to
bishops each a knight and two rooks each
three pawns on the King side each and
two points on the Queen side H each this
would you know be still anyone's game
but after this east sex move we have f4
here attacking Fisher's knight on e5 and
here he's his idea was if you move let's
say he could capture Bishop captures
pawn captures rook to c1 and it would be
actually Fischer who would have our
spawn structure and the white could
White would probably be pushing here for
advantage but here after a four he
missed one very nice move by Fischer and
that is Queen to a5 now you could play
rook to c1 and then figure out what what
to do then but in the game F captures on
e5 was played we have Queen captures on
c3 so a piece for a piece and now comes
the Queen to d4 Queen to deform in each
offers upon his idea is after Bishop
captures Queen captures Bishop captures
he wants to activate pieces rook to c1
after a bishop moves rook F to D 1 and
for the price of one point he will have
completed his development and perhaps it
will be sufficient compensation for a
further point but after Queen to d4
Fisher doesn't go for material rather he
plays the absolute best move
he plays if you want to pause the video
here and perhaps try to figure out which
remove Fischer played feel free to do so
now I will give it a couple of seconds
you know it's more of a you know a game
plan so for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations
so you have just played a move that
Fischer played and for those of you who
just want to enjoy it show the move is
Queen to a5 Queen to a5 is a very nice
idea because you attack White's Bishop
here and of course white cannot move the
bishop if you move the bishop let's say
Bishop to b3 then Bishop captures on e5
will attack your Queen here and also the
rook on a 1 so you will simply lose the
exchange here and of course the game
so after this Queen to a5 move we have a
4 you have to defend the bishop as you
cannot move it and now
comes bishop capture some b3 you lose
this phone here we have Bishop to f4 and
now comes a six attacking the bishop
Bishop to e2 and Dena comes to rook 88
rook to a3 d5 pawn is attacked three
times three times but first miniature
attacks Fisher's brush up on b3 Bishop
to b5 by Fisher and now rook the b1
preparing to create some sort of an
attack here we have Bishop to c6 and now
Nina CH plays Bishop to f3 and this of
course allows Fischer to capture on e5
but there was an even better move here
instead of Bishop to f3 there is quite a
lovely move here
it doesn't help white like in the sense
that white is immediately equal but it's
it's a better move than the one in each
plate so it's much harder to find this
one than the Queen a5 move you just have
to find so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find a move
most likely both of them missed as it's
you know it's a very strong engine line
but you know feel free to do it if you
if you're really up to the task
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations you you really you
know do play like an engine and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the move is actually Queen to b6
attacking Fischer's Queen on a5 and this
is the line now queen capture some b6
rook captures and after black captures
the pawn here Bishop captures rook
captures and the now comes Bishop
captures on a6
the whole point of Queen to b6
positioning the rook on d6 and now of
course if black captures the bishop you
will capture this bishop and then you
will be very very likely able to draw
this game and if black continues with
rook to e7 defending the b7 pawn then
you simply push a 5 rook to c8 defending
the bishop now you simply move the
bishop the back and you will most likely
after a 6 and exchange of these pawns 3
against 2 and on the King side a white
would most likely be able to hold this
if you know the best moves are played
but okay after Bishop to c6 Bishop to f3
was played and now comes the Bishop
captures on e5 Bishop captures rook
captures and now comes the
captures on c6 but B captors on c6 and
rook the c3 attacking Fischer's lonely
Paul and c6 and this was a miniature
idea he thought okay now Fischer will
have to defend probably rook c8 and then
after I attack Ruby c1 he's gonna have
to defend rookie six and with two
passive rooks I will have compensation
even though I'm down two points but not
likely after rook to c3 Fischer says I'm
not interested in defending the the
week's e6 pawn I want activity he goes
rook to eat too
so what do you do here as there is no
any current threat you might as well
grab a pawn so rook captures on c6
favorite place Queen to g5 this comes
with the threat of checkmate on g2 Queen
g4 defending and now Fischer exchanges
Queens we have Queen captures H captures
on g4 and now rook to d8 again Fischer
doesn't bother defending be a sex pawn
rather he gives up that bone as well to
go for a roof to d2 so now if something
like rook captures an a6 is played rook
d2 d2 is coming attacking the G to pawn
and after you try and pick up the King
you will White will have a passed pawn
here but the black will very easily stop
it with rook to a2 and then with three
points against one on the King side
Fischer will have excellent chances of
pushing for the win here so after rook
to d8 g5 was played but g5 with the idea
of rook to d2 Fischer now does not go
for Luke to d2 rather he finds an even
better idea now he goes rook to d5
because now he has a temple against the
g5 pawn and also then he will again be
attacking the g2 pawn
so okay king qf 1 now we have Brooke II
to e5 getting broke out of the way
rook captures on a6 and now rook
captures on g5 we have rook to be to
rook to d1 attacking the king
this comes with check rook King you have
to rock to a5 checking g3 rope the d3
check King goes back to h2 and in now
rook to a3 Fischer puts his rook behind
the passed pawn like I always say you
should always put a row behind the
passed pawn it doesn't matter if it's
your pawn or your opponent's pawn if
it's a passed pawn
then put a robe behind it rook to a7 and
here h5 we have King to g1 King to g7
rocked the be one King to h6 Fisher
improves the position of the King rook
to f1 and now rook captures on f1 with
King captures on f1 and now Fischer
pushes f5 here rook to e8 was played and
here dragged alumina ch without even
waiting for Fischer's reply decided to
resign the game it is three three points
against the two but like I said it's
it's a lonely pawn and on the Queen side
and the fish are already put a rock
behind the past pawn so King and three
points against the King at one point on
the Kings side will of course be winning
however you put it so yeah after
defeating Geller and the borislav if
cove in rounds twelve and thirteen
official now a beats that are called
mini in round 14 and once again
increases his winning streak so that's
the game round 14 of the 1970 Palma de
Majorca Interzone tournament I do hope
you enjoyed it and that you're enjoying
the coverage of the Bobby Fischer series
now that the bill festival ends today
we're gonna cover it you know more
continuously like maybe even to two
games a day from the Bobby Fischer
series I would like to thank Andrew veer
and the world over Hera Viera doneita
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon we'll continue in the
Bobby Fischer series but also with the
the last round of the bill chess
festival 2018 thank you all and I'll see
you soon